- How good could
be unless it's got dragons?
It's no fantasy unless
you have a dragon.
- Yeah, you need the dragon.
- Yeah.
You need the dragons.
And in my home institution,
the American Museum
of Natural History, we had
an exhibit a few years ago
that was all about
mythical monsters
and whether they
were the imaginations
of people who discovered
fossils of extinct dinosaurs.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
So imagine-- you
know a triceratops.
Yeah.
Imagine that emerging from
the eroding side of a cliff.
- That would be pretty--
- Right?
Pretty freaky.
Now you clearly know that
the animal you're seeing--
it's extinct.
But the concept of
extinction is a modern idea--
Yeah.
Of course.
--a few hundred years ago.
So here's this thing.
It can't-- it must
be some-- a monster
that we fear in the night.
And so didn't know about that?
No, no.
I've never really
thought about that.
Yeah!
I think you love
dragons because they're
great if they're your
friend, but if they're not,
they're a superpredator.
And that's another
theory, actually,
about where we have this idea
of dragons from that's even more
ancient than the idea of
people discovering fossils--
this idea that it might date
back to when we were very
frightened of apex predators.
An anthropologist
called David E. Jones
who puts forward this theory.
He studied vervet
monkeys in Africa.
And he noticed that
they are particularly
anxious about three predators--
lions, eagles, and snakes.
And so they have
a particular cry
that they make when they see
any of these three creatures.
Really?
And if you merge those
three creatures together,
you sort of get something
that resembles a dragon.
So he again has used
this to theorize--
So snake just gets you like--
Is the cry? [bleep]
Very similar, I think.
Very similar.
That's exactly--
HELEN KEEN (VOICEOVER):
Yeah, it's more or less.
You put it through the monkey
translator, it is so that.
HELEN KEEN (VOICEOVER):
Yeah, that's what comes out.
Yeah.
So when you think about it, if
you have something as ferocious
as a lion that has the body type
of a serpent such as the snake,
but it can fly as a flying
predator such as an eagle--
yeah, I'll give him that.
So that would be tougher.
So yes, he has this
idea that we would
have had this passed
down through millions
of generations.
We would have evolved
this fear that's
so great that we've created--
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON
(VOICEOVER): A primal fear.
--this amalgamation-- yes--
of these three predators.
Where does the
fire part come from?
We're all scared of-- we
would be scared of fire,
but that the idea--
They just added that
after-- say, we want
to make it even more ferocious.
ISAAC WRIGHT (VOICEOVER):
Oh, right right, right.